doing The Tonight Show I
I was making 30 million a year it was
ridiculous okay and NBC said well we're
gonna have to cut half the crew
you know so we had a big meeting I said
all right bro show hands how many fail I
should take a 50 pay cut so we can keep
everybody well I got out of voted that's
not what I got screwed on that one but
really
I already have 15 million dollars I'm
doing pretty good you know I never
thought I'd get this far and you know
something they were the best crew for
the rest of the days the legend is is
that you always kept all those tonight's
show checks oh yeah and made your money
doing live performances yeah corporate
things and stuff like that yeah I used
to live week to week did you literally
just put those checks you know in the
bank and I read the money I made as a
stand-up yeah I I wanted to be a
comedian how many years did you do that
until the very end I never touched any
of it